MISS LEAGUE.
THEY MISSED A LOT AND SEE IF
THEY CAN REGROUP AND BE MORE
EFFICIENT FROM DOWNTOWN IN GAME
TWO.
>> Marv: LET'S GO DOWN TO JARED
GREENBERG WITH BLAKE GRIFFIN.
>> Grant: >> Jared: MARV, MOST
REBOUNDS IN A PLAYOFF GAME FOR
YOU WITH 14 SINCE 2015.
18 POINTS.
YOU HAD ALMOST AS MANY THREES
ASSESS THE ENTIRE BUCKS TEAM.
WHAT WERE SAWING IN MARCH PEOPLE
TALKING ABOUT HOW BAD YOU WERE
COMING INTO THIS NETS TEAM?
>> I'M NOT EVEN FOCUSED ON THAT,
TO BE HONEST.
I'M JUST GRATEFUL TO BE HERE.
ORGANIZATION IS UNBELIEVABLE AND
FANS UNBELIEVABLE AND TEAMMATES
GREAT AND LET ME GET IN MY
RHYTHM AND LET ME DO WHAT I DO.
>> Jared: JAMES HARDEN GOES DOWN
IN 48 SECONDS INTO THE GAME AND
IS INJURED.
>> EVERYBODY HAS TO STEP.
BRUCE BROWN CHECKED IN AND DID A
GREAT JOB.
LANDRY.
MIKE JAMES.
WE GOT GUYS THAT WILL STEP UP
AND TAKE THAT CALL.
AND KEVIN AND KYRIE YOU KNOW DO
WHAT THEY DO.
>> Jared: WE ARE ON CLEAR FOR
JAMES' STATUS FOR MONDAY NIGHT.
YOU GUYS HAVE PLAYED SO MANY
GAMES WITHOUT A FULL ROSTER THIS
SEASON AND IN YOUR LIMITED TIME
HERE.
IN A WEIRD WAY, DOES THAT
PREPARE YOU FOR MOMENTS LIKE
MONDAY?
>> YEAH, IN A WAY IT PREPARES
YOU.
OBVIOUSLY YOU NEVER WANT TO LOSE
A GUY LIKE JAMES BUT LIKE YOU
SAID, WE HAVE BEEN IN THIS
SITUATION, UNFORTUNATELY.
SO I TRUST THESE GUYS.
I TRUST EVERYBODY.
WE HAVE HAD GUYS STEP UP AND
MAKE BIG PLAYS AND FILL THEIR
ROLES ALL SEASON LONG, AT LEAST
SINCE I'VE BEEN HERE.
WE GOT TO BE EVEN